I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions are you prepared
to call h a terror group is it possible
of a rational I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV he's a hero to many in the world and
a malicious misogynist to many others
but at this point just about everybody
has a view on Andrew Tate I've
challenged him repeatedly on the Macho
mentality that made him a global
internet Superstar I think my sister is
her husband's property do you regret
saying it like that a woman is given to
the man in marriage Andrew You're simply
wrong but just one week after our last
interview tapate was accused of much
more than bad taste Andrew and his
brother Tristan were arrested at home in
Romania on suspicion of rape human
trafficking and organized crime they
spent three months in jail awaiting
charges followed by 6 months under house
arrest their asset seized and they can't
leave the country and they're still
awaiting trial tonight in his most
explosive interview ever Andrew T gives
a blistering account of the he lost
everything and I hold him to account
over whether he's guilty it's emotional
there were tears that ran down my face
but I did not cry it's inflammatory the
last pure blood on the planet before I
inject myself with poison not making an
MGM trailer and it's unsensitive any
woman I love does not have to work
unless she decides right her job is to
work out for your benefit blah blah blah
blah
[Music]
Andrew it's
been well nearly a
year since we last sat down together
very different time it was in my London
studio and eight days after that you got
arrested what's the year been like for
you it's certainly been an interesting
one I've been constrained this entire
year I spent 93 days in a Romanian
dungeon 5 months locked in my house and
now I'm restrained within the country of
R Mania so it's certainly been a
turbulent time the moment you got
arrested it was all pretty dramatic the
video came out the world saw it a lot of
people smashing into your your home did
you have any inkling warning that
something like this may happen I knew it
I kept saying before I was arrested on
every single podcast I did I said you
get three lives in the world the first
life they're going to cancel you they're
going to slander you they're going to
delete your access to social media so
you can't defend yourself the second
life they're going to try and put you in
jail for no reason and if you continue
to speak against the power they're going
to assassinate you I knew I was on my
second life I kept saying it I knew it
was coming I didn't know the
reason they'd use but I found out once I
was in a
cell when you were arrested you you
didn't actually you don't speak any
Romanian at all zero and they didn't
speak English to you correct so you were
taken to a cell you had no idea what
they were alleging you done I was
arrested on the 27th of December so
because of Christmas and New Year's and
other problems they couldn't even
translate my paperwork for two weeks so
for the first two weeks I was in a
prison cell I had no idea why I was
given papers in Romanian I could read
human trafficking I understood but I was
like human trafficking who when what
none of this makes sense I waited two
entire weeks inside of my cell before I
was given an English translation and
then I realized exactly how ridiculous
the whole case was just to clarify I am
accused of helping my friends get big on
Tik Tok that is what I'm accused of I
told some girls I know how to post on
Tik Tok to become viral when I was at
the time the most viral person on the
planet and they are saying I'm a human
trafficker for that reason it is insane
you in
jail what was that like Romanian jail is
not English jail me describe it what was
the cell like I have to be careful what
I say because I don't want to insult the
Romanian justice system which I'm still
beholden to however it's exactly as bad
as people would expect it to be luckily
it was in the winter so the Cockroaches
were not too bad it was also during
Ramadan so I didn't have to eat so much
which was helpful because of the situ
situation I think the most stressful
thing about it is I had no idea how long
I was going to be in there for I was
dragged from my house I was given papers
in Romanian I didn't know why I was
there I found out why I was there and it
was garbage I couldn't seem to get out I
could have been held for years it's very
stressful and uh the best thing you can
do is turn to God and and train as hard
as possible I did thousands of push-ups
a day every sing were you in solitary
this in this period three months I no I
wasn't in solitary the entire month the
entire time sometime I was by myself
sometimes I was with other guys and
sometimes I was with my brother so when
you were on your own
were they keeping you in there for 24
hours a day were you allowed out no I
wasn't allowed out there was no yard
time it was 24 hours a day locked in a
single room probably three or four steps
large and you do nothing but stare at
the wall and you think how many days did
you do that for on your own 11 12 I mean
that's a
pretty Grim scenario for for anyone
life's Grim do you get emotional did you
shed tears in your C I'm an emotional
man I think I think men are hyper
emotional we just have to control it I
was extremely busy inside of my jail
cell I had lots of push-ups to do I was
very concerned about the people on the
outside I was trying my best to get
out it's difficult for me to answer the
question because it was a interesting
frame of mind I knew that God was
watching and I had to perform it's very
difficult for me to go through life
saying I'm the top G I'm this I'm that
and speak about mental resilience and
mental toughness and then the second I'm
thrown inside of a solitary confinement
cell cower out I'm not that person there
some there's some other people who talk
about mental toughness and want to give
advice and when bad things happen to
them they end up addicted to
prescription drugs I'm not a coward and
I'm not a liar but you
cried there were tears that ran down my
face but I did not cry I mean that's
crying I would disagree when you found
out what they were alleging you done
sexual assault exploitation and so on
what did you feel about that what was
your first reaction my first reaction
was ah the standard Playbook the
standard playbook for anybody who speaks
up against Power is sexual exploitation
isn't that the normal one they go to
can't we name like 10 or 15 people right
now they hit with this exact same
garbage I mean to be clear I don't know
if you're guilty or not I do sure you're
perfectly entitled to say that and you
know right of course I know but I don't
know and I will await any trial that
comes uh to see what comes out in the
trial and see what happens right so I'm
not going to prejudge the trial I'm not
going to judge you and say I think
you're guilty I don't know right we we
are where we are you've been charged
with serious crimes and it's likely
you'll face a trial and we'll see how
that all plays out obviously going back
to jail how are you treated by other
people everybody in jail was extremely
apologetic to me all of the staff the
police officers everyone who worked in
the jail the person who served me my
meal everybody was very sorry for what
happened to me they made it very clear
they knew it was garbage and they were
apologetic that was the only Vibe I
could give you they were kind of like
listen you got too big I'm sorry this is
how things work and sorry here's your
meal nobody had any real problem with me
none of the prisoners had a problem with
me did you get into any FS there was a a
a couple scenarios where violence could
have occurred but I think once people
realize that violence is a certainty and
that you do not operate under a fearful
realm they often aren't so interested so
people threatened you I wouldn't say
they threatened me but they would have
liked to have got the opportunity to
threaten me and what happened and they
realized that would have been a bad
decision one of the things I would think
about other than my family immediate
family but one particular member of my
family if I found myself in jail would
be my mother and what she would be
feeling and what she'd be thinking she's
been incredibly supportive to me I know
yours has to you did you think about
your mother I was extremely concerned
for her I was concerned because the
media establishment were hounding her
she was obviously very worried but she
knew she raised strong Sons but we're
her number one protectors and I was
concerned for her I I wasn't concerned
for myself in jail I didn't even suffer
in jail Mo as much as I did when I got
out I didn't have nightmares in jail I
had nightmares once I left jail I was in
the middle of a battle I don't think you
get PTSD while you're fighting you get
it afterwards I was in the middle of a
battle trying to make sure that
everybody I love and care about is taken
care of and trying to make sure that
bills are paid please understand the day
I was arrested which is a year ago every
single bank account that I have was
Frozen all of my assets were taken I
haven't had a a dollar of money car
taken I think 15 15 cars and some and
how many properties 15 cars six
properties 20 diamond watches gold bars
Cash Land every single bank account
millions and millions and millions of
dollars value of everything They seized
16 17 million pounds yeah and they took
all of it and I still don't have access
to any of these things I mean as we're
doing this interview you're expecting to
hear sometime today as to whether you
may get those possessions back is it is
it all or nothing do you get it all back
or nothing correct as we sit here the
judge is deciding whether I get all of
my items returned or I get none of them
returned and truthfully under the law I
should have never had them taken in the
first place so we're going to see what
the judge decides and I have to put my
faith within the Romanian judicial
system I have no other choice I'm not a
coward I'm not going to run when you
were released from jail off for about
three months what was that feeling like
I my my brother and I were in the same
cell at that time we were extremely
happy I remember using the last of my
mouthwash during the day I had some
rituals to keep me sane and I'd enjoy
one Swig of mouthwash a day it's amazing
how bored you get when you're staring at
cockroaches and even that sensation
there literally cockroaches in yourself
correct there was an infestation we did
our best to kill as many as we could it
kept us entertained but uh they're
annoying to sleep with
but mouthwash was something I enjoyed
every day the sensation of mouthwash
made me happy and I remember using all
of my mouthwash and then instantly my
brain started turning to all of the
things I need to do I'm a man I have
responsibilities for 93 days I wasn't
working I started concerning myself with
okay I'm about to get out of jail thank
God I'm going to leave who do I need to
take care of what's paid do I have any
money left are bills due is Mom okay are
my children okay and I just started
thinking about work and as soon as I got
out I didn't sleep for three days you
come out of prison you've got no ability
to access any of your assets how have
you been functioning financially since
then I believe in prayer and I trust in
God prayer doesn't pay the bills God has
been paying my bills so far it seems
It's amazing how far faith can take you
it's often when you have absolutely
nothing left people turn to Faith but
you should turn to Faith first and you
should believe in God when things are
good and he will be there when times are
bad we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any sub to it's hard to know whether
it's a f or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million P so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man M mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of mice
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what's what what's unfair
if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call Hass a terror group
is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that initially you were put on this sort
of rolling 30-day house arrest and they
kept renewing that month by month by
month and then in June you and your
brother and two others were formerly
charged with rape trafficking and
forming an organized crime group to
sexually exploit women and there were
seven alleged victims named in the
indictment you said at the time I look
forward to being found innocent um you
said earlier who are these women well
there are seven named in the environment
yeah have you seen the videos of them on
the Internet saying we're not victims
they made us be victims we told them
will all presumably be analyzed in a
trial do you know when the trial may be
I have no idea it's going to be a long
Believe will happen I'm not sure it
could get to a point where a judge
anytime before the trial decides this
case is garbage and throws it away if
you ask me what I believe happened it's
very simple they threw me in a jail cell
knowing they had no case knowing they
had no victims but they thought they
plaster me all over the MSM and they say
that I'm a bad person and they call
enough people they will find the case
they want they couldn't find it the
Romanian authorities prosecution files
uh accuse you of using verbal and
physical abuse to keep women in line
taking 50% I believe the women's online
income although I believe that figure
could vary could be up to 80% is that
right no they accuse me of exploiting
women who made who did Tick Tock the
same women who say we were not exploited
he just told us how to do Tik Tok also
in the in prosecution file if you want
to talk about it there's not a single
bank transfer there's not a single piece
of evidence for any money so I'm accused
of making money from Tik Tok but they
haven't found any money there's no money
and the victims are saying I didn't
exploit them to do Tik Tok the whole
thing is a joke I was in jail because I
spoke against Power because I told the
truth about Co because I told the truth
about the war in Ukraine because I told
the truth about all of these things I
don't understand why people would want
to put you in jail for giving your
opinions about covid or Ukraine why
would they why wouldn't they why would
they why would they say why would they
say that Andrew Tate's opinion is so
important on Ukraine that we have to put
him in jail I don't I don't buy that
okay because I was the most Googled man
on the planet and I had a huge Affinity
with the most troublesome demographic
for the Matrix which is the young
masculine youth the people who you need
to die in Wars the people who you need
to sop into being slaves to build the
roads while telling them that they're
not allowed a point of view and they're
not allowed an opinion on anything and I
was saying things which was going
against the narrative and the Matrix the
way it operates is it uses the MSM to
purport lies to inject slave programming
into people's brains so that we live
lives which are not good for us but are
good for them and I was sitting there
unplugging it what is the Matrix The
Matrix are a bunch of people who come up
with studies from the sky to say
anything they want them to say so they
can use the MSM to report garbage inside
of people's minds so you end up locked
in your house clapping for the NHS like
a performing seal injecting yourself
with experimental poison for the ninth
time it's a lie there was no reason to
lock everyone in their house more people
died from missed cancer appointments
than anyone ever died of covid people
always got the sniffles before Co and
they've always got it since let me ask
you a question where is co gone diseases
don't go away where's Co gone it wasn't
well Co strains have got Milder has
indeed flu did flu used to kill gone
away well flu pandemic in about 100
years ago killed 50 to 100 million
people and it's got steadily milder over
the decade since this is normal medical
science uh pathway for most pandemics
right so on that I mean your sort of
cast IR it was all Matrix MSM nonsense
is palpably untrue well I'll tell you
why that's not untrue let me tell you my
personal experience with Co I'm an
extremely logical person at the
beginning when everyone was dying
dropping dead in the streets in China
which I never saw by the way funny and
the Italian hospitals were full English
hospitals Were Never full funny me and
my brother sat there and said if this
disease is so deadly and can damage us
as strong military age males and the
world is over so there's no point in
hiding in our house we decided to go to
Sweden on day one of covid day one when
everyone still believed we went to
Sweden why does no one talk about the
fact that Sweden was open the entire
time why does no one talk about the fact
they didn't have masks or lockdown or
vaccines my brother and I par e in
nightclubs seven days a week for three
entire months while everyone in England
walked in their house Sweden actually
had a number of restrictions not when I
was there open not as Draconian as we
had in the UK and there were certainly
legitimate questions to ask about the
scale of our lockdowns I think people
panicked they saw what was happening in
in Italy which had the second best
Medical Health Care system in the world
and people were dying in massive numbers
and the hospitals were overrun so people
may have panicked did you hear about the
guy who died in a motorcycle crash and
it was a covid death you hear about that
one well there was certain Downing
Street didn't seem very concerned with
there there was a long debate about
people dying of covid or with covid I
know all that but the bottom line for me
it is
indisputable that covid was a deadly
pandemic that killed a lot of people it
turned out a lot of older people more
than young people but they didn't know
that at the time not for a long period
the vaccine saved millions of people's
lives there are legitimate questions
about some of the boosters about some of
the side effects of the vaccines as
there are by the way with all vaccines
but the idea that Co is some invention
by The Matrix to suppress and control
its people is for the birds Andrew it's
for the birds it seems the birds and I
are friends don't think a smart guy like
you actually believes that of course one
of my problems one of my problems I have
with you is that I think you are
intelligent but I think you also adopt
positions that you know are going to get
the an you know the anti-matrix mob
inflamed and it's just these
all-encompassing views you have covid
was a load of nonsense vaccines are all
dangerous and killing more people than
they say said that I the covid vaccine
well covid vaccine well you don't think
they worked no of course not because the
idea of a vac the the the word vaccine
in and of itself is that you get they
save millions of lives if you get a
vaccine you do not get the disease they
changed the definition of vaccine in the
dictionary so they can continue to
inject us with this pointless poison I
had the vaccine for polio I've never had
Polio you got the vaccine for covid and
you're bragging online how you have Co
for the eighth time but it's not that
bad because you've had six injections
it's insane and please understand my
position please understand that I'm a
person who doesn't believe any of these
studies don't believe any of this
garbage Don't Believe The Matrix I'm a
person who was in Sweden for 3 months as
everyone was afraid locked in their
houses partying at will and it was
perfectly fine they had a lower death
rate than the UK they had a much higher
death rate than their neighboring
countries in Scandinavia did you know
that they had a lower death rate than
the UK did you know that it doesn't no I
didn't know that doesn't matter to you
of course not so you wouldn't compare
them to their immediate neighbors you'd
only compare them to a country in the UK
If you think lockdowns worked Pierce if
you think lockdowns I think lockdowns
were only acceptable as an immediate uh
Panic move which it was before there
were vaccines the moment they had a
successful vaccine program that worked
then there was no justification for
further lockdown you're a very important
person and you're very well respected
I'm not important I'm a journalist no
you're very important and you're very
well respected within the UK and you've
been famous for a very long time were
you invited to the party at Downing
Street or were you not in that sort no
no that's a shame and I thought the they
seemed very concerned about Co on the TV
and they didn't seem to give a soon
as the TV was on disgraceful and I
thought Boris Johnson and the people
working at number 10 who were having
those parties uh when I had friends of
mine who were literally saying goodbye
to their mothers on FaceTime on their
phone because they weren't allowed in to
see them and you people in Care Homes
where it ripped through and killed a
third of the people in the home in two
weeks and the desperation that people
felt had a cousin who lost his father
who couldn't go and see uh his dying
wife and so Ong why don't we just agree
that they were a bunch of rank
hypocrites
stupid people who were behaving utterly
selfishly to the extent that the queen
when her husband Prince philli dies is
in the church on her own in a mask with
none of her family around her after
losing a rock of 70 years and it turned
out the night before down the street had
had I think two parties including a
karaoke party I think that was shameful
and disgraceful well I we can agree on
that we can agree on that and we can
wake up and start to realize oh maybe
the government doesn't care about us
maybe the government lies to us maybe
they tell us things and try and scare us
but they don't actually care themselves
maybe all they are is hypocritical
self-interested people maybe they are
let me ask you about the lover boy
method so the suggestion is that you and
your brother and others U but you let's
talk about you that you deploy the lover
booy method where you would make women
fall in love with you you would then
persuade them to do uh webcam webcam
stuff right Tik Tok okay but wait let's
call it webcam stuff right no let's not
call it that the indictment is about Tik
Tok okay what would you make the women
do but what would they do with you I
don't make anybody do anything in fact
let's talk about the lover boy method so
it's very interesting let's Imagine The
Matrix is pissed off with a said
individual who's telling too much truth
and everybody is listening to him and
they decide they're going to attack him
with sexual assault claims they say ah
he's making women do well we found
conversations where he gave advice on
how to go viral on Tik Tok he's making
women do Tik Tok but he isn't being
horrible to them he's not hitting them
he's not being mean to them so what can
we do let's use the lover boy method if
I was abusive and mean they wouldn't say
lover boy method you know what lover boy
method means being nice he was nice and
polite and kind and they really liked
him as a person and he told them how to
do Tik Tok he's a lover boy of course it
is Andrew that's not what the lover boy
method is absolutely it is the lover boy
method is where perpetrators woo victims
with the prospect of a loving
relationship until they can be forced
into abusive situations or a form of
slavery this is garbage that's actually
what it means the lover boy method is
being nice to people so that you work
together effectively what they're trying
to say here I was nice to girls who
asked me for Tik Tok advice and they
sang It's the lover boy method I didn't
beat them into doing Tik Tok I didn't
force them I didn't threaten them in
fact I was like yeah you're very pretty
you can be pretty famous was any element
of coercion How can there be an El what
does that even mean let's be
professionals here what does that even
mean what do you think coer means I was
coerced into this interview you came
along to me and said you weren't coerced
into this is yes I was well don't tell
me the bullying MSM said Andrew you've
got to do an interview I'm going to fly
all the way to remain to do it you
didn't do that you used the lover boy
method you said sir lover boy method y
Andrew this is going to be a very
interesting interview we had a good one
last time you're a nice guy we have some
interesting conversations I'm going to
come along we're going to make some
money from this interview money will be
made for both sides you rub boyed me and
you stole the profit minute just to be
clear I've had no conversation with you
about this interview and the
conversations I've had with your
intermediary were very professional and
I said I would like to do an interview
were you nice I wasn't nice to you and I
didn't call you a nice guy I feel lover
boy H I feel lover boy I'm sorry well
sorry it's
fine we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know I love about to today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appr Palestine that is just
not right you swear an Al in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from at Gram was president
of the Cambridge Union which is the
rubbish version of being president of
the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan about Twitter you
sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call terror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV you had a a website husters
University offering courses teaching
husbands and boyfriends how to get their
Partners absolutely false the husters
university which you can go to now
actually we've changed the domain it's
University
is a school which teaches modern wealth
creation methods we teach people how to
make websites we teach people Ecom why
did you call it why did you call it a
PhD pimping hose degree no you're
talking about an old video which was
made satirically why did you call it
that oh Sati of course it was nine years
ago the internet was a very different
place and if you're going to sit here
and say oh nine years ago you said
stupid things on the Internet it's not a
gotcha moment because every single
person has so of you Al University
teaches children how to make websites
and it teach and it's there only one
reason I'm ask only reason I'm ask you
you've repeatedly said in interviews
since you were arrested that you have
never categorized yourself as a pimp you
don't think you're a pimp right well
what about all the rappers did you ask
Ice Cube if he's a pimp and a murderer
and a drug dealer JayZ sold crack
talking I'm not interviewing them I'm
asking you whether you have any stage in
the last 15 years being a pimp of course
I've not been a pimp I've said I'm a
pimp I've said I'm an astronaut I've
said I'm a cowboy I've said I'm the
strongest man in the world I've said I'm
James Bond throw me in jail you just put
me in jail I deserve it nine years ago I
made a joke on the internet so here's my
question are you are you a fantasist I'm
not a fantasist do you have a Persona
that's just not you of course not I am
me well if you are you why would you
repeatedly call yourself a pimp and then
now say you never been a pimp I
exaggerated on the internet 9 years ago
for comedic effect I'd walk into a
nightclub and there'd be girls at my
table like every other man who walks
into a nightclub and I'd say Pimpin oh
no put me in jail 93 days was not enough
with the Cockroaches I should go back
this is a matrix attack Pierce every
single person every single man out there
is has done things worse than I've done
in fact I will argue if you put 99.9% of
men through the level of scrutiny I've
been through by F by multiple federal
agencies you will find a lot worse than
him saying he was a pimp on the internet
nine years ago you will find actual
genuine crime and I've done nothing I
live true to God this is all garbage and
it's not real I want to be clear to you
I'm not preempting your guilt I've come
here with a completely open mind you've
been charged with serious offenses but I
am not going to judge you because I'm
not a judge and this is not courtroom
right but it's interesting to me that
one of the biggest charges against you
is that you're a misogynist and you've
always said I'm not a misogynist and
last time I interviewed you said well I
may have said some things that you know
may have been misconstrued but even in
the last week you've tweeted some stuff
which I'm not even sure if you're aware
as you tweet this stuff how it sounds
read it okay let's read this is quite a
long one sure but I think it's important
to read it to get a sense of how you
view women absolutely any woman I date
does not have a job um okay so the woman
you're with doesn't have a job no okay
do you date other women sometimes and
your partner's fine with that obviously
yeah and you you're fine with that why
wouldn't I be well you think it's fine
to be dating other women when you're
when you you have a mother I think we're
consenting adults and everybody can make
their own personal decisions okay fair
enough why would I be working so hard
you say to have hundreds of millions of
my woman to waste her life enslaved
pennies no I will give you a life you
can never ever afford private jets
festar hotels new cars endless spending
money and diamonds you'll be rich
because you're praying for me every day
and protecting my spirit I work in the
physical world she works in the spirit
realm would women shouldn't have to work
because being a good partner is a
full-time job for a woman she has to
look good all the beauty treatments are
time intensive not about money it takes
a lot of time she has to train every day
and stay in fantastic shape Shops look
amazing next to me I know there are some
men who do a hundred times more than
this on a daily basis but women are not
as organized as men and achieving
anything significant causes them huge
amounts of stress yeah they need to have
huge sections of their day empty to
waste or they will have a mental
breakdown true and do you want a woman
who's stressed and angry after the
commute unshaven and exhausted or do you
want a Barbie doll who's always smiling
and saying thank you because she did her
nails and brought you proud of that day
as a man unless you're a loser you're
already Filthy Rich right you can get
endless sex anyway Girls Are Easy so
what can a girl give you happiness Vibes
always smiling take the edge of a
stressful life can she always be happy
if she's been working all day no just to
wake up at 11:00 gym till 1 one up
appointment and some shopping dress
Beautiful by 7:00 p.m. for you to finish
working and tell you how strong you are
no matter how pissed off you are you
just to always be laughing and smiling
and writing little notes about how
you're perfect and just to be playful
and funny she can't do that if she has a
job so your job is being my girlfriend
and now you're a millionaire
congratulations behave and aim for the
promotion to wife the reason I read all
that in detail was I don't think you
understand quite how that comes over
because I think that is the purest
definition of misogyny I probably ever
read well I don't think you understand
one especially when I'm talking about
the fact that women can't handle what
men can do Etc one it's slightly
sarcastic there's a sarcastic toone do
you mean any of it no I mean it but it's
slightly sarcastic sarc comic effect
sarcasm means you don't mean it no I
mean it but it's slightly SAR you mean
it or you don't it's either sarcastic or
it's not I think a man should provide
for a woman financially completely and
utterly if she wants to work if my
partner were to say to me right now I
really feel like getting a job it would
make me happy then I'll say work but she
doesn't have to her job is looking after
the children looking after me and being
as happy as possible if you think I'm a
bad person for saying if you actually
read that read the subtext and context
okay good then you'll understand what
I'm saying you know I did you heard it
absolutely so what I am saying is I am a
man my life is stressful my life is pain
I go to jail I suffer I have to deal
with making money I have constant
endless headache I do all of that so I
can give you everything but then I get
to have you your job is to be happy I
want you to smile I want you to look
your best and feel your best all of the
time if I'm I a misogynist for saying
that I go through so much pain so that
we can be financially secure so I hope
the woman I care about does not have to
work a job if that makes me a bad person
then so be it because all I'm saying is
I want to take care of her in every
single realm I take care of her physical
safety I take care of her Financial
Security that is my job as a man and if
more men acted like me you will see that
the world will be a happier and better
place the women who say I really want to
work I want a career that's their
prerogative and their decision they're
allowed to do that but also often the
reason they do that is because they
can't find a man they trust to take care
of them I've had this I've had this from
women in their own mouth if I found a
man who was financially secure and as
smart as you I wouldn't be doing this
garbage job either why was I sced into
working to pay taxes when I should be at
home having children with a man door
Andre a s Andrew there are so many women
that will listen to that and be laughing
and mocking you say don't be so
ridiculous I have a job but I love maybe
they're being paid even more than their
man right the real world isn't the one
that you categorize the real world is
varied and nuanced but I am talking
about my life experience and my
experience any woman I love does not
have to work unless she decides right
you're the boss you're in charge her job
is to make you happy her job is to make
herself look good her job is to work out
for your benefit blah blah blah blah
blah it is actually just misogyny do you
think a woman looking good do you think
a woman looking good and working out is
has no benefit at all to her of course
it does okay so it's not for my benefit
then is it when but when you talk when
you talk about no no I don't when you
talk about young men and you tell them
to work out and take care of themselves
I cheer you on right I want that I've
got three sons I want them to feel that
don't you want them to become very rich
and successful and have a woman who
relies on them and have a beautiful
family no but I don't want a woman who's
subservient to them why is subservience
why is a woman the tone of the tweet I
read is sub service you did another
tweet this week men Love by telling you
what to do and not allowing you to make
stupid decisions we save you from the
female inclination to make stupid
choices if a man isn't give you
instructions he doesn't love you if you
won't listen to a man's instructions you
don't love him the whole language is so
ridiculous let me change the language
then well you tweeted this to 8
absolutely 8.2 million people correct so
let me say this a father loves let's say
instead of a man loves say a father
loves a father loves disciplinarian
that's how a father will love you a
mother will say oh I hope you're happy
hope you're doing okay but but a father
will come along and say no don't do this
you must do it that way that's incorrect
it has to be this way a father will
discipline you because a father feels he
knows best for you it's the masculine
essence of Love When a Man Loves he
cares via degree there is a massive
difference between a relationship
between a father and a child and between
a man and a woman in a relationship
completely and I'm not sure you quite
get that no there is a difference but I
would argue Pierce I would argue in the
happiest relationships it's a
traditionally masculine role in which
the man plays and provides the female is
traditionally feminine the man is the
head of the house not in an abusive way
doesn't beat her up I'm talking about
the man being the head of the household
like I would like to believe you're the
head of your household and he comes
along and says what happens and what
doesn't happen yeah listen it's all good
Macho stuff okay and I know lots of
young boys who listen to this and go wow
that's how I should be then I read the
detail of your tweets and again come
back to this we save women from their
female inclination to make stupid
choices females are emotional if a man
isn't giving you instructions females
are
emotional f are emal all this stuff is
designed to exactly as you just
articulated is designed to make young
men feel that the only way they can be
successful in life is to effectively
have their women under control give them
instructions that they buy them they
have to obey don't Don't Buy Women
you'll end up in jail you can buy them
Prada but let me let me finish my point
my point is that it seems to me from
reading your tweets even now that you
have a blind spot when it comes to how
they sound and it may be and it may be
that the legal problems that you're in
which might be extremely serious and
we'll see when the trial happens but it
may be that in your head nothing you've
done is remotely inappropriate because
actually in your tweets you can see
there's an element there of wanting
coercion and control you want to control
women you want them to be effectively
your servants slaves for want of a
better friend slav slaves who get Prada
and get to work out in the gym and get
to look good while I do act you
understand the point I make it no I
don't because which is in your head the
line is blurred so much now with this
Macho rhetoric that you've actually lost
track of how this sounds here's all of
the things I even when I read that stuff
to you I could see you looking at me and
you said your answer is I was being
sarcastic and I said well where then you
go well no I meant it well you can't be
both I meant it and I said sarcastic
tone mean it or it's well no because
sarcasm means you don't mean it Pierce
all the things you've just you accept
that no I smart guy you know what
sarcasm means absolutely I said it has a
sarcastic tone for comedic
effect we're here thanks for joining us
you with talk TV on TV on radio online
onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon had the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it hard know whether it's a
FSE or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pounds so far so 140 million so
far result nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbias news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that's is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald Milk mous Man Mouse
man mous man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of mice
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what's what what's not
fair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call Hass a terror group
is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that you tweeted a picture of Amanda
Holden very good friend of mine uh it's
a very harmless picture she's in a
bikini on holiday under a rain shower uh
looking extraordinarily uh beautiful and
a sexual pose and you tweeted you are a
wife and a mother and you're far past a
teenager there's no need for this post
agreed again it's just misogynist to say
that it's not misogynist what kind a
woman of her age she's just turned 50
what kind a woman of that age actually
show off her beautiful body in a in a
nice bikini like that what's wrong with
that you can call me crazy you can call
me misogynistic but I think once you
reach the ripe age of 50 any woman
should not be interested in thirst
trapping on Instagram I think she has
bigger responsibil I I'm sure she's a
very intelligent lady and she's done
amazing things she's famous she's
obviously very capable and I think she
could do things more interesting than
standing around trying to thirst trap on
Instagram like she's 18 I think she's
above it I wasn't insulting her I was
reminding her that she's actually such a
fantastic person she's done such amazing
things in her life and she's so achieved
that she's actually above thirst
trapping I was reminding of her of her
worth because as a feminist we're all
feminists here right we all believe in
women empowerment I'm reminding of her
her of her worth are you a feminist sure
I believe in feminine empowerment and I
think feminine empowerment is in yes I
do and feminine empowerment is in
modesty modesty is empowering for Fe for
females believe taking your clothes off
for men on Instagram is not empowering
it's empowering when you say no man but
my husband can see my body that is
female empowerment and I was reminding
her of that I was reminding her of her
ripe age and her intellect and there is
no need for that how old do you know I
am 36 36 years old correct at what point
will your antics you know chugging your
cigars in your ripped body in your
compound with your security and your
Bugattis at what age does that become a
thirst trap I don't know if that ever
stops being a thirst trap because so
it's fine for you once again one rule
for the man another rule for the woman
it's interesting because I've never
heard this argument before but I'm
extremely intelligent and I've already
deciphered how this is going to go from
head to toe it's called I guess we can
look at peacocks right the male peacock
he shows look who I am look look what I
can do look at my achievement look at my
beautiful feathers and I guess you could
call it peacocking to a degree I'm
showing the world I'm extremely I'm
extremely physical cap I'm extremely
physically capable yes that's correct
I'm extremely financially successful you
stripping off for Instagram is fine it's
not stripping off for Instagram I'm
boxing when you box you Bo you have no
top on you do it all the time with your
cigar and you're showing off your Rip
but that's fine for you but if a man to
Holden dares do it that is apparently
thirst trapping I think me boxing with
no shirt on is different than a
50-year-old woman po you don't just box
I've seen you doing ones where you
wander around all Moody with your cigar
and your topless and stuff so fine for
you are you a fan Pierce uh no I just
think it's first trap do you yeah well I
don't do that perhaps it's successful
you maybe you should start perhaps it's
successful because I do have a lot of
female fans out there in the world and
they pretend I'm a misogynist but it
turns out that 85% of women on the
planet seem to agree with me every
single woman I've ever met in real life
agrees with me I have no female hate at
all I've never had NE negative
interaction with women ever yes you have
with who there are lots of women I know
personally there are lots of women who
find you incredibly offensive I don't
think so right it's their right to it's
your right it's your right to not care
but the idea that somehow you're this
beloved person for the world's females I
think is uh not true you are for a
certain type of woman who likes to be
treated in the way that you like to
treat women well let's counter that
argument right because the world as I
said at the beginning is nuanced am I
beloved by all females no but when I'm
sat here with someone as prestiged as
you who says you're a misogynist and you
hate women and women hate you I think
you talk in a way that is misogynistic
yeah okay well then you make it sound
like all women hate me and that's also
not the case of course it's a new on say
all women hate some some women agree
with me some women don't agree with me
when I said that post about Amanda
Holden a lot of women said Andrew that's
actually completely correct she's
extremely famous and there's no need for
her to be posting video pictures like
this at her ripe age I was actually
empowering her I believe that female
empowerment is in modesty but you don't
actually believe in feminism I believe
in the idea of you believe in
masculinity controlling women no they
have to take instructions from you they
have to do what you tell them and that
is actually what love and relationships
are about no I believe that men and
women have different roles I believe
that we were created differently by God
because we are the perfect team I
believe that a man who's in his
masculine frame is best suited by a
woman who's in her feminine frame I
believe when we work together we can
achieve amazing things whether it's
raising children or preserving society
and I believe a man has certain jobs and
a woman has certain jobs you don't
understand this about the things I say
when I said there that women make bad
decisions in the Tweet you referenced
earlier the point I was making is that
women are more emotional than men that
is their superpower that is fantastic
that is a great thing I love female
emotion in the Tweet before you tried to
use against me I was talking about how I
love a woman to be happy all the time
smiling all the time while I'm stressed
I love female emotionality the reason
women are better with children the
reason women are better with children is
because they're emotional that is their
superpower in a position you're not even
remembering what you WR of course it is
I said female women are more emotional
than men is exactly what I said I'm
saying that is a fantastic thing but
there is no light without dark so in
certain situations the emotionality is
positive in certain situations the
emotionality is negative we can also
argue the same for men because what
happens with me is everyone tries to
gender my arguments we can actually
argue the same with men stoicism male
stoicism is positive in certain
scenarios it can be negative in others
we can come across as unempathetic or
not care because we're stoic but in
certain situations it benefits I know
people who've told me that their kids
are in their late teens they're at
schools where the name Andrew Tate is
banned nobody's allowed to mention your
name because the teachers think that
your brand of masculinity is so toxic
they are seeing a immediate effect on
the way that young men behave and not in
a good way is that what the teachers
think is it yeah well I am actually
genuinely concerned by the fact that
I've been banned from schools when I do
nothing but preach masculine strength
and Excellence but then if you actually
understand how the society is going and
how the world works and all the insanity
they're trying to push on all of us I
can understand why they banned me
because I speak the truth if I was
wearing a wig Pierce and lipstick and
telling young boys to remove their
genitals would I have been banned from
schools no they would have say oh you
could say his name no problem no matter
how big I got if I had a wig on and
lipstick and I had been castrated
medically I would be allowed to talk to
the young boys but as soon as I say
You're supposed to grow up and get big
and strong and if your wife doesn't want
a job you need to pay for her it's your
job as a man you better find some money
garbage on that last point you don't say
if a woman doesn't want to work and
manag to take care of it you say a woman
shouldn't work I said my woman won't
work right I'm talking about my personal
experience I said any girlfriend of mine
but because I'm an extremely fortunate
financial position I was before Romania
took everything of course I have
hundreds of millions of dollars so
because I am in my position I would not
might want my woman to work I think
there's more important things she can do
you have hundreds of millions of dollars
where you said you had a worth of 17
million no I said they took 17 million
years so where's the rest uh they must
have taken it I think they have it or
maybe I lost it I think I lost it
somewhere you you've never had hundreds
of millions of dollars of course not we
haven't have you of course not you said
they took all your assets exactly well
did they or didn't they of course they
took everything I mean they'll be
watching this are they to assume that
there are hundreds of millions more
dollars they haven't got yet they're
watching this that's right they take
absolutely everything you have it all
right but again is that all just the
smoke and mirrors is that all just the
the top G stuff that you play up to
which is has no bearing on reality I was
the most Googled man on the planet I was
the most relevant man amongst 18 to 35
year old males which are the highest
earning and spending people on the
planet do you really think that I am not
I can't pay my bills Pierce right now
yeah okay someone's paying them for you
correct you're right someone's paying
them for me you're right my girl's got a
job she works at Starbucks exclusive
Andrew tapes girl top G's girl works in
Starbucks to pay the rent I've been
exposed see again I don't know what to
believe when you say stuff like that
well I'm telling you my friend that the
remaining stat I think you deployed
deliberate smoke in mirrors because you
think it plays up to the brand Romanian
State have taken all of my money and I'm
just you know getting by mhm that's what
happened do you worry about your impact
on young men I think that I like I said
I'll be completely honest I think a lot
of what you say they should be hearing
yeah and I have tangible proof every day
when I walk around that they are
listening to everything you say but
there is other stuff you say where I
don't want my sons especially in that
impressionable late teenage to be
listening to that correct and that's a I
don't want my daughter to grow up and
think that actually her only success in
life will come if she's at home as some
kind of servant to her man well that
won't be her only success but that's an
actual that's a very professional
question and I'll give a very
professional answer I have a massive
responsibility with great power comes
great responsibility and I understand
that young men do listen to everything I
say I do think I say good things but you
also made a very pertinent point there
you talked about the impressionable age
of a teenager and it's very easy for a
teenager with their hormones and their
lack of life experience to take the
things I say and weaponize them and use
them in the incorrect context however
that is not my fault You could argue
that 16 17 year olds look at anything on
the internet and misunderstand it you
could argue that all of this transgender
garbage and all of these rappers talking
about killing each other and all these
drill artists talking about stabbing
their enemies could be misunderstood by
a 16year old so that's not my fault
however on that I totally agree so I
have a massive responsibility and you
are held to a different account actually
to a lot of those rappers absolutely
right there's no question I mean the far
of me is when John Legend rewrote the
lyrics to Baby It's Cold Outside because
apparently encourage sexual assault but
wouldn't say a negative word about any
of the disgustingly misogynist and and
actually very violent lyrics of his rap
friends that to me is total hypocrisy
and it is H hypocritical however unlike
all of these other people I have taken
into account my massive power and my
massive responsibility and I try to make
sure that I use my words as carefully as
possible so that they cannot be
misconstrued or misunderstood can I make
sure that no teenager on the planet who
listens to me ever misunderstands me
ever no I can't do that but I am doing
my very best what do I actually talk
about what do I actually say I what I do
is I come along and let me give you the
broad overview of my message you're a
man so your life sucks it's always going
to suck and it's going to be pain you're
going to do nothing but suffer you're
going to suffer as a nobody or going to
suffer the pain it takes to become
actually most men don't have that but
that you're going to suffer as a nobody
because trust me nobody suffer or you're
going to suffer the pain it takes to
become great life is not supposed to be
a happy picnic you're supposed to get up
work hard dedicate yourself get strong
get rich go through whatever it takes to
become somebody of significance That's
My overall message and I believe it's a
positive you got to get rich to be happy
no most in fact most of the super rich
people I know in life are incredibly
unhappy so you're selling a kind of full
stream well I don't a lot of rich people
are miserable have you ever seen a rich
person give Mone L people who have very
little money can be very happy have you
ever seen a rich person give their money
away yes of course okay do you give all
your money away will I make you happier
Pierce I don't do you want the Romanian
state to take it all I didn't smile that
day and let me tell you that the reason
I tell about men to become financially
successful for two reasons one because
you have a job as a man to protect and
provide you can do neither of those
things if you are broke that's the first
reason and the second reason I actually
preach to young men to become as
financially successful as possible is a
greater broader reason and I believe
we've entered a very interesting stage
in humanity where the Matrix is finally
cracked three or four years ago there
were certain narratives you could not
talk against but with Elon Musk owning X
and now we have Rumble we have a lot
more information on the internet people
are starting to tell the truth about
many different subjects there's a whole
bunch of them we can name and I like the
idea of people who are free thinking
with a free mind not Matrix control
making as much money as possible because
it takes money to win Wars and I want
these people to be financially
successful that's why I tell all of my
fans who believe in me to become as rich
as possible because they understand that
everything the government does is lie to
them we need Finance you use the word
truth there I don't think it's
necessarily that people want to promote
truth they want to promote their
opinions often people's opinions on
facts can be very different people can
take the same set of facts and different
opinions doesn't mean it's the truth
right well that's true but I don't
believe in this my truth crap right NE
neither do I there are facts which have
to be accepted then you can have an
opinion about them you and I can
disagree about all sorts of opinions but
actually not facts okay but I can argue
this point where the Matrix comes out
with a fact and all the opinions
countering that fact are censored and
they are destroyed then that fact
becomes de facto truth because it's the
only version of reality which exists to
be ingested by the mind so you still
need varing opinions on all public do
you think that what you uh let's let's
put it this way sure you would have
relationships with women and encourage
them to take part in webcam sexual stuff
no well actually yes why are we going
back to this cuz there's one question I
want to ask you about it right and both
sides made a lot of money sure right you
think what you've been making money from
Park the illegality aspect to one side
do you feel it was moral do I think it's
moral because you speak in such a
morally self-righteous way now do you
think that that was moral well I wasn't
religious back then but let me sit and
anal you're now you you converted to
Islam correct you're Muslim they have
you know a code of behavior do you think
that that fell short of I have to answer
as a professional and as a professional
I would say judging by my current code
no I do not think that women being naked
on the Internet is moral however there
is like so you made money immorally you
can admit that it's nuanced like all
things Pierce at the time I was
atheistic I know that some of my girls
talked men away from suicide a lot of
men are ridiculously lonely I would also
say a lot of the lessons I know about
men and how they think and how lonely
and sad they can be and how difficult
life is as a man actually came from that
era because I saw a lot of very
successful men with a wife and with kids
and with money pouring their heart out
to some 20-year-old they never met about
how sad they were I learned a lot about
the world and I know that a lot of
suicide was prevented and I made a lot
of women millionaires but would I do it
now no however I'm in a very different
situation now I'm a different person I'm
religious I'm also extremely financially
successful please understand Piers I
come from Marsh Farm Luton I came from
one of the worst areas inside of the UK
I could have stabbed someone every my
friends are breaking into cars breaking
into houses most of my friends are in
jail what did I do I promoted accounts
on the internet didn't didn't sell crack
didn't sell drugs didn't rob anyone
didn't shoot anyone and now because I am
successful I'm going to be held to this
moral standard by people who grew up in
fancy homes with white picket fences who
went to private schools I am from Marsh
Luton and the biggest crime I committed
was completely legally promoting
internet profil tomorrow night on
uncensor what is your view of this world
is a genocide and it's disgusting and it
doesn't matter which side of the
political Spectrum you fall on do you
believe Hamas are a terror organization
and that's a very interesting question
but I think you're pedaling asini why
are you being flippant I'm not being
flippant the point I am making I find
that funny nothing justifies what
happened October so what are they
supposed to do I'm mad I'm emotional now
let's go kill everyone I think that was
one of the best interviews ever
conducted with Andrew I actually I don't
know how hard you're going to go on
me
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
antiemetic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from play in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom